economía en france 24 me acompaña en el
estudio daniela blandón daniela muy
buenas noches comenzamos en américa
latina chile y brasil van a preparar
nuevas medidas económicas para hacer
frente a la crisis del joven 19 que
sigue dando problemas estás santiago
buenas noches qué le parece si empezamos
por chile el presidente de sebastián
piñera envió al congreso un proyecto de
ley para entregar un bono de entre 500
58 y 836 dólares para quienes ganen
menos de 2 mil 800 dólares al mes y que
hayan visto caer sus ingresos en al
menos una tercera parte también
contempla un préstamo sin intereses con
un período de gracia de un año
cumpliendo con ciertos requisitos para
los ciudadanos y también la extensión
del subsidio a la renta
plan económico para recuperar los
empleos perdidos ayudar a las pymes
reactivar nuestra economía de los 2
millones de empleos que perdimos ya
hemos recuperado la mitad y vamos a
seguir recuperando los que aún nos queda
por conseguir y vamos a brasil ahora
porque el congreso aprobó que se retomen
por cuatro meses del programa de
subsidios mensuales a las familias de
bajos recursos este había expirado en
diciembre pasado aunque el monto va a
bajar de 55 a 45 dólares
y hablemos ahora de cuba porque abre un
poco más las puertas a la inversión de
los extranjeros que otros países llegan
a invertir así en la isla danesa y
santiago este país lanzó un portafolio
de 503 proyectos para inversionistas
extranjeros y cubanos que residan afuera
del país esto es algo novedoso teniendo
en cuenta el estricto control comercial
de la isla y que las autoridades han
sido muy celosas a la hora de permitir
que los empresarios cubanos emigrados
lleven su capital de vuelta se esperan
inversiones por 12 mil millones de
dólares en sectores que van desde
ingeniería y energía hasta pequeños
emprendimientos resolviendo
el problema
alimentarios y no alimentarios
conocemos las limitaciones que tenemos
antes
y puede ser hasta menos de un millón de
dólares los proyectos en que estamos
interesados promover y concretar y de
cubanos vamos hasta españa los
trabajadores digitales serán
considerados empleados allí en este país
europeo si santiago el gobierno llegó a
un acuerdo con los sindicatos y los
empleadores para que los repartidores de
plataformas digitales tengan un contrato
laboral
esta es una novedad en la unión europea
y les otorgaría beneficios como
vacaciones pagas e incapacidades por
enfermedad el proyecto que no necesita
aprobación parlamentaria ahora queda en
manos del consejo de ministros para su
promulgación pero muchos de esos
repartidores no están de acuerdo con la
medida pues piden que puedan ser ellos
quienes escojan si quieren ser empleados
o independientes una medida que será
seguramente seguida en otros países
daniela la onu dio señales de alarma por
el aumento del hambre en el mundo entero
por supuesto desencadenado también por
la pandemia cifras al cierre de 2020 más
de 88 millones de personas en el mundo
sufre
de hambre aguda un 20% más que en 2019
naciones unidas dice que hay unos 30
millones de personas al borde de la
hambruna como consecuencia de la
pandemia también pero de varios
conflictos armados como los que tienen
lugar en el sahel africano y se aceleran
en sudan del sur de yemen y afganistán
veamos algunos de los ejemplos de sudán
del sur enfrenta sus niveles más altos
de inseguridad alimentaria desde que el
país declaró su independencia hace 10
años el 60% de la población pasa cada
vez más hambre los precios de los
alimentos son tan altos que un solo
plato de arroz y frijoles cuesta más del
180 por ciento del salario promedio
diario el equivalente a unos 400 dólares
aquí en nueva york' yo tenía la de cómo
les fue las bolsas en la jornada de
ahora los principales parqués en el
mundo en el paquete de estímulos
promulgado por el presidente yo byd en
impulso de las bolsas del mundo incluido
wall street que cerró con recortó en dos
de sus índices europa también cerró
positivo algunas de las bolsas a punto
de tocar nuevos máximos y en américa
latina' el mercado brasileño vio con
buenos
la aprobación de subsidios y subió
hablemos ahora de la cifra del día para
el cierre 69 4 millones de euros en este
valor santiago grave se lo acaba de ser
subastada por la casa christie's la
primera obra de arte digital del mundo
es un collage titulado todos los días
los primeros cinco mil días son cinco
mil imágenes digitales unidas una por
día creada desde mayo de 2007 por bieber
que ahora es uno de los tres artistas
vivos más valiosos el arte digital
tomando ventaja gracias daniel as todo
en la economía en france 24 siga con
nosotros buenas noches